-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night." We hope
you're doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
During a speech at
the White House yesterday,
President Biden joked
about turning 60 instead of 81.
Man, nothing drives home
how very old you are
More than joking you're only 60.
That's still
discount bus fare old.
During the White House
turkey pardon yesterday,
President Biden
appeared to mix up
Taylor Swift and Britney Spears
and, just like that,
lost 30 million votes.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. During the turkey
pardon yesterday,
President Biden
appeared to mix up
Taylor Swift and Britney Spears.
Wow, that's almost
as bad as the time
former President Trump
called Tim Cook Tim Apple,
thought Frederick Douglass
was alive,
called Second Corinthians
"Two Corinthians,"
called Kevin McCarthy Steve,
called Paul Ryan Ron,
walked out of
an executive order ceremony
after forgetting to sign
an executive order,
and suggested injecting
bleach to kill COVID.
[ Laughter ]
Almost as bad.
Still, Britney and Taylor?
In a newly released letter,
former President Trump's
physician said
his overall health is excellent
and his physical exams
are within normal range.
But take that
with a grain of salt,
because the letter also said
his coat is shiny
and he's negative
for heartworms.
[ Laughter ]
Also, he wrote -- They scratched
out "Rex" and then his name...
The White House celebrated
President Biden's birthday
last night
with an Instagram post
showing him blowing out
a dozen -- dozens --
dozens of candles --
dozens of candles on a cake.
And just a quick question
for the Democratic Party,
is anybody in charge of PR?
[ Laughter ]
You want people to forget
how old he is,
and you serve him up
a birthday cake
that looks like a garbage can
fire at a hobo camp?
Hey, you ever heard of these?
Yeah, those.
That's what you want.
Still says he's 81, but at least
it doesn't set off
the White House
sprinkler system.
Vice President Kamala Harris
this week launched an account
on the social media
platform Threads
and, just in case,
one on LinkedIn.
[ Laughter ]
Just in case.
A lamppost fell on three guests
yesterday at Disneyland's
Main Street, USA,
and it was still more fun
than The Hall of Presidents.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Iowa arrested
a man last week
after he was allegedly
masturbating
outside a Kum & Go
convenience store.
[ Laughter ]
This news first reported
by every one
of my writers today.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, boss, did you see
the good news?"
"Yeah.
It's not good news."
"Hey, did you hear?"
"Yeah!
Are you in a line out there?
Get out of here!"
And finally, according
to a new survey,
nearly half of Americans
are traveling during the holiday
season to visit loved ones.
The other half
are visiting family.
[ Laughter ]
And the writer who wrote
that joke's name is Bryan,
and if you're...
if you're his family,
now you know.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
We're off and running.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's going to be a good one
tonight.
We got a great show
for you tonight.
She is the Emmy-winning
co-host of "CBS Mornings"
and the editor-at-large
of Oprah Daily.
The winter issue
with Oprah's Favorite Things
is on newsstands now.
Our friend Gayle King
will be on the show.
Very happy to have Gayle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He is an Emmy-winning actor,
and his portrayal
of Logan Roy on "Succession"
is an all-time
great performance.
His acting tutorials are
available now on BBC Maestro.
Brian Cox will also be here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm very excited because,
you know,
the finale of "Succession" aired
during the writers strike.
We didn't have the show
during the actors strike.
He hasn't really had a chance
to talk about "Succession."
I'm very excited
to talk about it.
Logan Roy is truly
one of the best.
And, I mean, I'm probably
just saying that
because he reminds me of my dad.
[ Laughter ]
His acting --
Oh, sorry. We moved on.
[ Mutters ]
You know her from
"Only Murders in the Building"
and "The Idol."
She stars in the wonderful film
"The Holdovers,"
which is in theaters now.
Da'Vine Joy Randolph
will also be joining us,
and that movie is good.
That movie is good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanksgiving show
Thursday of this week,
the guests are going
to be my parents,
the guests -- the other guest
is going to be my brother.
Also, if you can't wait,
my brother and I have a podcast
called "Family Trips
with the Meyers Brothers."
And this week,
a very special episode.
We asked our listeners
to call in
with their Thanksgiving stories.
Very funny.
And then
if you just want to listen,
you can hear people
like Amy Poehler
talk about her family trips
or my good friend John Mulaney.
Very funny as well.
So that's the podcast.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Moving on,
here at "Late Night,"
every night
I deliver a monologue
made up of jokes written
by a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight white male,
would be difficult
for me to deliver.
But we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them,
so we'd like to share them
with you now
in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
-Surprise! It's the 50th
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
-Can you believe Seth
let us do this 50 times?
What a freaking idiot!
-To celebrate,
we planned a fun surprise.
-Well, fun for us.
-And we did not tell Seth.
-Just to be clear, Seth does not
know what's about to happen,
but he's probably
already figured out
he's not gonna like it.
-So hold on to your butts
for this brand-new,
extra-special
50th "Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
-Make way for those who tell
the jokes that Seth cannot!
[ Horn blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello!
We are two of Seth's writers,
Amber and Jenny.
-Now...
[ Laughter ]
...is it going to be the same
script we read earlier today?
-Well, we'll find out.
-No, it will not.
[ Laughter ]
We wrote a whole script
for nothing!
[ Laughter ]
And then he approved the jokes
like a freaking idiot!
-And he gave us notes, and we
wrote them down with pencils.
-"Oh, we're going to fix it."
-"Okay. Good idea, Seth."
-We met three
different times on it!
-[ Laughs ]
-And this man has no free time.
-Also, I can't believe you had
Ian dress up like that.
-Yeah. Why not?
-That was the main point.
-Just so you know, based on the
costumes and the budget cuts
we're going to have to make,
Ian's gone.
[ Laughter ]
Last day.
Amber is Black and Jenny is gay,
and they're both women.
-And Seth is not,
so normally he reads the setups
to the jokes
and we read the punch lines.
-But this is a special occasion.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So this time we're going to
do things differently.
We are going to read the setups
and Seth is going to read
the punch lines,
and he's learning that right now
as I'm saying it.
-And it's going to go great,
and there will be
no repercussions for him
telling these jokes!
-And he's going to feel super
comfortable the whole time.
-Ready? Here we go!
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
A new play will open in London
next year
called "Cowboys and Lesbians."
-Said audiences,
"I can't tell which is which."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-That's how you wanna start
then? Okay.
-Wow. That is really...
I am a little ashamed.
A team of all Black women
is planning to climb
Mount Kilimanjaro next year.
-Word has it
there's a nail salon at the top.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Gasps ]
Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
How dare you?
-Wow!
Wow, we're only going to give
you eight more chances.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah, that was second?
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm.
A coffeehouse in Ithaca
recently created
a social group for lesbians.
-A social group for lesbians?
Or, as it's more commonly known,
the military.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa!
-Wow.
Wow.
-This is real champagne?
-Yes. Yes. Yes.
-Yeah.
-You think this ain't
a real margarita
you got another thing coming.
-We chose it --
We chose it to go
with your real discomfort.
[ Laughter ]
-According to a recent article,
due to the stress of racism,
many Black Americans
are leaving the US.
-"That's too bad,"
said white people lying.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-Wow.
-I don't...
-Guys, I cannot --
I cannot believe he said that.
-I can't either.
-I can't stress enough
that's not what's on the card.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Wow.
-Don't know where he got that.
A reporter recently
apologized for asking
the captain of Morocco's
national soccer team
if any of her teammates are gay.
-He meant to ask, "Are any
of your teammates not gay?"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Wow.
-Okay.
-Should we leave
or should we do more?
-I guess the only way
to fix this is to do more.
-In a recent interview,
Lauryn Hill defended
arriving late to her concerts.
-Said Black fans, "It's fine.
We're late too."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, wow.
-Why did you shrug?
Like, what...?
-Like why would you like...?
Like it's no big deal.
Like racism --
-It said "shrug" on the card!
-I did not see that.
-You guys should be so impressed
with how well I've read this
exactly how you've written it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Considering what I'm going
through right now.
-He cannot stress enough
he's never seen these cue cards.
-We rehearsed this in my
dressing room before the show,
and today I heard, "Their hair
and makeup is taking too long.
Are you fine not rehearsing?"
I was like, "Of course
I'm fine not rehearsing!
Those two are the best."
-[ Laughs ]
-But aren't we?
[ Clears throat ]
Excuse me.
-[ Laughs ]
-A recent article
in "The New York Times"
profiled several lesbian
ballet dancers.
-And they all had
one thing in common.
They all wear these.
"Open draw."
Lesbian ballet dancers.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
-That was pretty good.
-That's pretty good.
-Pretty good.
-Yeah. Good job, Sethie.
-This desk is a sacred place.
[ Laughter ]
-More like was.
Princeton University's
newspaper recently published
an article titled
"African American Studies
Is Meant for Everyone."
-Unlike Princeton,
which is meant for white people.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Wow.
-The speed with which
he said it.
-Yeah.
-"White people."
-[ Indistinct ]
-You know what?
I'm starting to
get in the groove.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you know what?
Now I'm just going to do them
all with pure enthusiasm,
like I believe it.
-Okay. Alright.
-Uh-oh.
[ Laughter ]
-I have literally --
We've almost done
1,500 episodes of this show.
That's the most audible "uh-oh."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And I think
there were two of them.
-It was like
the audience member was miked.
-Yeah.
-[ Clears throat ]
-Subaru is planning to introduce
three new electric vehicles
by 2026.
-So now lesbians will own
two things
that are battery operated.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-You girls know
what I'm talking about!
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, yeah, but...
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey, guys! Why don't --
Oh, yeah. You guys.
Hey, why don't you tell one?
-Oh, no. We couldn't.
-Oh, come on, just tell one.
-I don't feel like
it'll end well.
-Do it.
-Okay.
A new show about the life
of Melissa Etheridge
has opened on Broadway.
And this is cool --
Melissa Etheridge
will be played by Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-How dare you?!
-You told us it would be okay!
-You both should be ashamed
and delighted with yourself.
[ Laughter ]
-Straight white men are liars!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We'll be right back
with Gayle King!
-Stick around!
-I'm very impressed.
-[ Laughs ]